hello and welcome to another video today
we're going to be talking about high
school prodigies have it easy even in
another world so without any further ado
let's get into it seven japanese high
schoolers are prodigies in their fields
politician and prime minister of japan
tsukasa genius inventor ringo ninja
journalist shinobu medical doctor kane
samurai swordsman aoi magician prince
akatsuki and businessman masato survive
a plane crash only to find themselves in
another magic world where humans with
animal-like features called bumas live
alongside the humans the prodigies are
rescued and treated by an elf girl named
li rule as the people of elm village
celebrate the prodigy's recovery they
learn of the legend about seven heroes
from another world who saved the
continent from an evil dragon so
believing there might be a connection
tsukasa instructs his friends to learn
more about the new world and its culture
so they might be able to find a way back
home and also help improve the welfare
of elm village using their advanced
knowledge and skills to repay them when
soldiers of a local feudal lord tried to
extort the villagers for food and wine
the prodigies defeat and scare them into
leaving the villagers alone and never
tell their lord about the incident
despite this the prodigies continue
their plan while they help in their own
way
masato and elk run into trouble
acquiring money and supplies for elm
village and they discover the neuter
land company monopolized the right to
trade in dormunt while the rest of the
high schoolers do various odd jobs at
the village shinobu uses her skills to
dig up scandalous information on the
mayor of dormant allowing masato to
acquire a permit to trade under the name
elm trading company after taking in a
homeless girl masato and elk visit some
local merchants and offer to help them
sell their wares they're planning to
undercut neutral land by charging less
and only taking 10 percent of the
profits from each sale masato's shop
quickly becomes popular selling
everything from ranks to tsukasa's
homemade mayonnaise and sends money and
supplies to elm village neutral and
dismisses the elm trading company as a
nuisance at first but when the sea
serpent maritime merchant company begins
trading with masato neutral and decides
to take the threat seriously setting up
a rival store to undercut elms prices
and drive them out of business masato
shows elk several bumas standing outside
hinting that they're part of his plan to
destroy neuter land for good meanwhile
neuter land's plan backfires as the
merchants they find to save money signed
a contract with masato the head of the
neutral and company admits defeat and
makes a deal with masato over sharing
trading rights in findoff as masato was
talking with elk slave traders attempt
to capture back the little girl but
masato buys her freedom and the young
girl promises to masato she'll become a
great merchant to free her parents from
slavery sugasa and other prodigies build
a public bath house for elm village but
suddenly a giant bear attacks the
villagers wounding the village chief
away defeats the bear and kane heals the
old man's wounds meanwhile masato and
his companions return to elm village
only to get arrested by soldiers of
marquis findol fled by his knight he
falsely charges the villagers for
treason with his absurd claim it's a sin
for peasants to touch gold the knight
orders the villagers to be burned inside
their homes as punishment but akatsuki
manages to free the villagers before
tsukasa and the others arrive where they
learn the knight has kidnapped lee rule
she's forced to become marquis findovs
concubine in exchange for the lives of
elm village but a mysterious magic
protects her when findoff tries to kiss
her meanwhile sulcasa and the prodigies
help the elm villagers rescue li liru
and start a revolution to overthrow the
corrupted empire and make it into an
advanced modern democratic nation where
everyone is equal and has rights thanks
to ringo's rail cannon metal arrows and
jewel looming shields the prodigies and
elm villages are able to storm into
findov's castle and fight his soldiers
easily while shinobu and tsukasa sneak
in to rescue li rule while shinobu holds
off the imperial mage officer tsukasa
enters findol's room where lee rule is
but is shot by findo's flintlock pistol
however tsukasa survives unheard thanks
to his suit being made of bulletproof
fibers and takes out his own handgun the
marquis begs for his life but tsukasa
shoots him with a rubber bullet instead
since the prodigies actions and ideals
have already made them enemies of the
empire and they won't stop until the
revolution is complete as everyone
celebrates the defeat of findoff's army
sukasa plans his next task of forming an
independent nation the prodigies start a
religion called the seven light faith in
order to easily convince the people to
accept them as rulers of their nation
using akatsuki's magic tricks and free
gifts of mayonnaise they can convince
the people of dormant to switch their
allegiance from the empire to the seven
light faith sukhasana later makes a deal
with the mayor of the city to continue
serving as a mayor and show allegiance
to seven light faith he also talks with
the former captain of the city watch to
become the leader of the newly formed
seven light night order after convincing
the captain that his daughter's future
in their new nation is worth fighting
against the empire meanwhile shinobu and
elk learned that the empire is sending
an army to reclaim findover from the
prodigies led by duke gustav a war hero
and notorious control freak at his
castle gustav kills one of the knights
for running away rather than fighting
the rebels and vows to burn them asugasa
implements his political reforms and
modernizes the livelihoods of the people
his ministers and friends are worried
he's working too hard with the empire
planning to attack findoff in the spring
sukasa modernizes the seven lights army
by having ringo build a power plant and
a factory to mass produce guns to
prepare for the upcoming invasion later
that night leeroy confronts sukasa in
his office where he tells her he used to
admire his father the previous japanese
prime minister until he learned how
corrupt his father was and with the help
of his friends he exposed his father's
corruption which got him arrested and
then executed this damaged his
relationship with his mother since she
loved her husband and never forgave
sukasa since then tsukasa devoted
himself to becoming a selfless
politician for the people this saddens
lee rule who tells that she'll never
hate him meanwhile shinobu and elk state
and inn at the village in gustav's lands
despite the villagers proclaiming how
great their villages shinobu becomes
suspicious after noticing none of the
villagers are eating the food that they
serve despite starving themselves she
and elk soon discovered the dark secret
of the village the villagers have been
secretly drugging travellers before
killing and eating them when jugustar
soldiers punish a little girl for having
dirt on their clothes during an
inspection shinobu gives herself up to
their leader silver knight jean in
exchange for sparing the little girl as
she tried to warn them to leave the
village elk confronts the little girl's
mother over the dead travelers which she
apologizes about and explains that their
village was once a normal farming
village but when duke gustav took over
their lands he forced the villagers to
turn it into a beautiful town using the
villagers own money and ordered them to
always keep their clothes clean meaning
they could no longer farm for food or
earn money his obsessive rules put a
toll on the villagers lives to the point
where they were forced into cannibalism
just to survive which many of them
regret meanwhile jean frees shinobu and
reveals that she's actually a member of
the azure brigade who opposed jukostar's
tyranny and asks for her help elsewhere
dukastar becomes angry upon learning his
army has yet to attack the rebels at
findov and decides to take action by
using his magic spear heaven's flames to
destroy the city tsukasa and ringo learn
about the attack and use almost all the
anti-aircraft missiles in findoff to
redirect the spear into the ocean but
the spear manages to evade the last
missile and hits the city despite
managing to evacuate the people and
preventing the fire from spreading
jukestar summons fire spirits from his
spear to kill the people and spread the
fire further leeroy reveals to the
prodigies that the being which possessed
her has told her they need to destroy
the spear to stop heaven's flames from
spreading using their last missile ahi
volunteers to escort the missile and
protect it from gustar's fire spirits so
he can destroy the spear the missile
destroys the spear and stops the heavens
flames which is felt by gustav who vows
revenge on the rebels as the prodigies
help the people of the city leeroy
reveals the being that possessed also
gave a knowledge of magic and the
ability to speak with spirits so she
wants to learn how to use that magic to
help thanks to information by shinobu
that juke gustav won't be able to use
another heaven's flame for some time and
working with the azure brigade tsukasa
orders a surprise attack on gustav's
army led by zest and 50 soldiers armed
with winter gear and guns
gustaf orders his marquise and their
forces to invade findoff despite their
protests as attacking unprepared during
the winter is a horrible idea their
forces are forced to retreat after being
driven back by zest forces thanks to
their guns and grenades before both
marquis surrendered to the seven light
faith at the same time the azure brigade
attacked jude gustav and his men at the
castle jean and shinobu confront gustav
and order him to surrender but he
refuses leading to the fight between
them they defeat gustav but not before
the duke blows himself with his magic
seemingly killing himself after the
seven light faith and azure brigade take
over gustav's lands and restore order
the prodigies have a meeting on whether
the asia brigade can be trusted and
become allies tsukasa concludes that the
azure brigade is hiding something from
the prodigies and can't be trusted
especially their new leader before they
can move forward with their plans kane
tells tsukasa and ringo to take some
time off before they collapse in
exhaustion from their overworked
schedules later tsukasa gives ringo an
important task shinobu discovers conrad
is planning to have the azure brigade
rejoin the empire just as tsukasa
predicted of their portrayal elsewhere
an epidemic is spread amongst the
commoners which kane attempts to cure
despite suffering a medicine shortage
however people of the medical guild
demand kane to allow their guilt to sell
opium to the sick but kane refuses with
the help of liberal's magic and cain's
knowledge of chemistry they turn the
coal into medicine making enough to cure
all patients the medical guild attempts
to poison the medicine to ruin the seven
light faith's reputation but is stopped
by kane who subsequently lobotomizes
them into faithful people meanwhile
ringo finally finishes her latest work
at the empire general nero allows conrad
and the azure brigade to rejoin the
empire but wants them to destroy the
seven light faith whose ideas of
equality go against the empire providing
them with an army and a mysterious fire
mage elsewhere conrad's knight in his
men attempt to kill jean but she's saved
by shinobu who then kills the assassins
jon's devastated after learning her
comrades have betrayed a mentor's
original goals of the asha brigade of
improving the welfare of the people and
joined the empire while jean and shinobu
discover gustav's golden statue in
conrad's castle conrad returns with the
fire mage who shinobu recognizes the
fire mage is revealed to be gustav in
disguise and kills conrad for smashing
his golden statue he then turns his
attention to jean and shinobu attacks
them they escape but not before gustav
destroys the castle killing all the
guards as he marvels at his new powers
gustav suddenly blown up by ringo's
newly built ballistic missile the site
of the blast is seen from dormunt the
next day the prodigies give a speech to
their citizens where tsukasa reveals
that they are now one nation known as
the elm republic and must defend
themselves as a republic not under a
dictatorship while giving the speech a
pillar of fire suddenly appears
revealing gustav who transforms into a
demon and attacks the prodigies
aoe and shinobu attempt to dispatch him
trying to destroy the gem and gustaf's
chest but they're knocked back gustav
leaves towards tsukasa who pulls out a
handgun and destroys the gem as the
demon reaches him as he dies gustav
warns sukkas of the trials ahead of him
and boasts that the prodigies will never
succeed elsewhere a trio from the yamato
empire and general neuro observed the
events in dormant with the latter
proposing that the seven light faith may
be an obstacle for him
so this is it for today's video if you
like the video give it a huge thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel for more
videos farewell till next time